[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETE LEPAGE: Well, hello
everybody, and welcome to
another edition of Chrome
Apps Office Hours.
We've got--
joining us today, we've
got Joe Marini.
Joe, do you want to introduce
yourself?
JOE MARINI: Sure.
Thanks, Pete.
I am Joe Marini.
I'm a developer here on the
Chrome team and I work on
Chrome Apps.
PETE LEPAGE: Sweet, and
I'm Pete LePage.
So today we're going to be
talking about the new Alarms
API, which allows you to create
specific events that
fire at specific--
or create events that fire
at specific times
or on regular intervals.
With any kind of native or
installed app, one of the
things you might want to do is
have regular events that go
pull for data, or maybe you're
writing something like an
alarm clock, and you want to
have the application notify
the user of a specific thing
that happened, or that it's
time to get up and it's
time to do something.
So with the Alarms API,
you can actually
go in and do that.
You can much more easily say,
hey, even though my
application is not running right
now, I want to go and
fire a specific event
and have something
happen with that event.
So it's a pretty cool API,
pretty useful to use and it's
really, really simple.
Normally, our shows run
about 30 minutes.
I think today we may actually
even finish up in about 15
minutes because this is
a really simple API.
Why don't we go ahead and jump
in, and we'll take a look at
how the API works.
So let me just open these guys
up here so that we can get
this going, and we'll
have a look here.
So there's a relatively easy
way of creating an alarm.
It's chrome.alarms.create and
you give it a name, which is a
string, and an alarm info,
which is an object.
So the string can be anything.
You just use that to identify
what the alarm is, and then
the alarm info has the
details about how
the alarm gets fired.
So there's a couple of things
that you could put in here.
So first thing you could
have is when.
So that's a specific time you
want the alarm to fire.
So if you want it to fire at
say, now plus 30 minutes,
you'd say, date.now times 60
seconds times 1,000 times 30.
So that gives you the 30 minutes
because it gives that
time n number of milliseconds
past the [? epoch. ?]
The other option is you can say
delay in minutes, which
provides the, hey, I want to
fire in 30 minutes or I want
to fire in 45 minutes.
So that's just a double if you
want a specific, hey, just
hang out for a certain amount
of time and then
fire this guy off.
You can use either
delay in minutes.
And then finally, period in
minutes is another one that
says, hey, I want you to refire
this event every so
often, so however many minutes
you want it to refire in.
Now, all three of those are
optional, but realistically,
you need at least one of them
provided, so you need either
to provide the when or the
delay or the period.
You could also do two of them,
so that you could say when
plus period or delay in
minutes plus period.
So you could say, hey, I want
you to fire this event in 30
minutes and then wait 30 minutes
and fire it again and
fire it again and
fire it again.
So that way you can have that
recurring, hey, go check to
see if there's any new data or
maybe you want to go and do
something else with that.
So like I said, they're all
optional, but you should fire
at least one.
If you don't apply anything,
the alarm just fires right
away, which is kind
of pointless.
And then, of course, you need
to listen for the event.
With the Alarms API, it fires an
event when the alarm fires.
That was repeating myself just
a little bit, but that's OK.
And so you just say
chrome.alarms.onAlarm.addevent
and then the function name
that you want to do.
And of course, you can do an
inline function, and you'll
see that in a sec when we
take a look at the demo.
And it passes one parameter,
the alarms parameter.
And in the alarms parameter, it
gives back the effectively,
the alarm info that
you provided.
So how often you want it
to fire as well as
the name of the alarm.
So that's it.
It's pretty simple.
Joe, is there anything you
want to add to that?
JOE MARINI: Yeah, just a
couple of quick notes.
First, we should point out
that there's actually no
strict guarantee that the alarm
will fire exactly when
you scheduled it to.
PETE LEPAGE: Good point.
JOE MARINI: Sometimes, due to
performance reasons, if
there's a lot of alarms
scheduled, for example, we may
delay the alarm some arbitrary
small amount of time so that
all the alarm events don't
pile up in the system.
The other really cool thing I
love about this API, is that
it works even when your
app is not running.
You skip an alarm, and then the
user closes your app, and
the alarm comes along and your
app will actually be woken up
and told that the alarm fired.
In past programming paradigms,
sometimes developers would try
to find a way to keep their app
running all the time so
they could do some kind of
polling or whatever.
You're using the Alarms API
and some others we have
available as well, it makes
it so you don't
have to do that anymore.
You can just schedule a periodic
event that says,
regardless of whether my app is
running or not, I need to
know when this thing fires.
And this is a really great
utility for doing that.
PETE LEPAGE: Exactly.
Yeah, that's a good point.
In the past, you might have done
things like set interval
or set timeout to
go and update.
That works, and it's functional,
but it's a lot of
code and it's just more
work than it's worth.
With this--
JOE MARINI: And once again, it
doesn't work when your apps
not running.
If your app gets terminated for
some reason or whatever,
that code just-- the minute it
goes away, your code goes
away, so Chrome Alarms API
helps solve that problem.
PETE LEPAGE: Exactly.
So I'm going to come out of my
slides here, and let's just
have a look at a demo
that I've got here.
So we'll take a look at the code
first because I think the
code is most interesting.
So there's a couple of things
that I want to point out
within the code, so within the
manifest file, you need to ask
for the alarms permission.
You need to just say, hey, look,
I want to be able to
fire alarms.
So relatively simple permission
ask here, so I just
said alarms.
And then, the way I design this
app, I wanted the alarms
to be able to be handled
whenever
the app wasn't running.
And this was something that, as
Joe just mentioned, if you
wanted the alarms to be handled
when the app is not
running, you need to put the
event listener into the main
JavaScript files, so into the
main JS, into the place where
you're listening for
all of the events.
So you can see here, I've got
my chrome.alarms.onAlarm dot
add event listener.
And I'm just doing it as an
inline function, so I say,
function alarm, looking
for that alarm.
And I'm just going to do a
console log just because that
way I can see what's
happening.
And in this particular case, I'm
just going to throw up an
old style WebKit notification.
Really, the better way to do
this-- and I threw this
together in about five minutes
earlier today--
but the better way to do this
would have been to use one of
the new notification APIs, which
we talked about last
week, or maybe, I guess,
it was the week before.
One of the cool things about
that is that you can use those
really easily, and they just
came out of experimental, so
you can use those without
the experimental flag.
So then finally, we've got--
we show our notification,
so create notification.
And I'm just using the alarm
name because I just wanted
something simple.
And for the body of the message,
I'm just going to
stringify the object so that
we can see what's going on,
and then we show it.
Within the actual app--
if we have a look at the HTML
for a sec, you can see it's
pretty simple.
I've just got a form where I
take in the name for the
event, a time, and
an add alarm.
So that within the actual
application code, I've got the
add for time, where I go and get
the date and time, or add
for delay so that I can say,
hey, I want this to fire in x
many minutes.
So let's take a quick look, and
I'm going to set this guy
for delay for two minutes
and add alarm.
So you notice that the time
went away, so we've
got this guy going.
So in about two minutes, up in
this upper right hand corner
that you'll see,
I think it's--
yeah, right above my head,
right about there.
We're going to see an alarm
notification that'll pop up.
We could also use the specific
time so I want to
set this for 12--
whoops--
for 12.
Let's set this for 12:15
PM and add alarm.
So I've added that, and I had
everything spit stuff out to
the console so we could
see what's going on.
So we can see that there are
alarms here that are
available to us.
So the first time when I click
it, you can see-- and let me
just make this text a little bit
bigger-- you can see that
we have all of our alarms,
which I just used
chrome.alarms.getall, and
then printed the output.
So we've got our delay one,
along with the scheduled time.
And the second time we did it,
we've got for a specific time,
and the time that it's
going to fire.
So there's the scheduled time
and the name of it.
Now, I think I see a bug
in my code here.
I was playing with this a little
bit earlier, and this
has to be a double, and this
happens to be a float.
So we may end up having this guy
not quite work, so we'll
see what happens in a sec.
I think I know why.
So the other thing that I want
to have a look at, is if we
inspect the background page
here, you can see that no
events have been fired.
When events get fired, we'll
have that guy fire off.
So if we go back and have a
quick peek at my code--
let's see, so we're doing
our delay in minutes.
We're doing a parse int with
the for delay and that
shouldn't be a--
Alarm fired, but we didn't get
our notification popping up.
So you can see that we got
our delay popping up, but
actually, this is maybe not what
I was thinking it was.
Joe, do you see anything
with this?
JOE MARINI: No, not right
off the bat, I don't.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Well, we can see that the event
fired, so that's the
important thing.
JOE MARINI: That's the important
part, exactly.
PETE LEPAGE: And the important
part here is that when the
alarm fires, its firing off in
the main event so it's being
handled in the main event.
That means, like I said,
you can have
these events fire off.
You can go get new data.
You can pop up notifications.
You can do anything that you
need to do so that your users
know what's going on, and that
your users know all the stuff
that they need to know
about or that your
app stays up to date.
It's a really great way of
capturing data locally and
catching stuff going on.
So Joe, anything you'd
like to add?
JOE MARINI: Well, of course, the
API gives you ways to see
what alarms have been scheduled,
clear any specific
alarms, clear all the alarms.
It's a pretty full
featured API.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
All right, so let's say pop over
to questions, and we can
bring up their questions URL
because I know that we had a
few questions already.
And we'll take some
of your questions.
So you can ask your questions,
the link is that way.
There we go.
The link is down that way if
you have questions that you
want to ask about this.
The first question we'll take,
can we use the API to remove
cookies from other domains,
either time based or click
based removals or anything
like that?
And the answer to that is no.
Joe, do you want to
collaborate on
that a little bit?
JOE MARINI: You have to remember
that one of the
security models that we built
into Chrome Apps is that
cookies are all isolated from
each other, so you can't just
go poking into other cookies.
So the short answer is no.
There's an isolation
model in place.
You've only got access to any
cookies that you've personally
set and [INAUDIBLE].
The whole cross domain thing
gets really hairy, really
quickly, so for security
reasons, no.
PETE LEPAGE: Exactly.
So this is not something that
you're going to use for
removing cookies or anything
like that for other places.
You might use it if you want
to remove your own cookies,
but that's about it.
So the second question here,
are there any use cases for
alarms that you feel have been
underutilized for developers
or that you'd like
to see more of?
To be honest, I don't think
we've seen many
uses of this API yet.
So--
JOE MARINI: It's still
relatively new.
I'm actually kind of excited to
see how it gets used, but I
think there are some pretty
usual suspects use cases, but
I'm actually kind of excited to
see what comes along that I
hadn't thought of.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
The main things that come to
mind for me are things like
caching and storing data.
So for example, a news app or
maybe a photos app, might want
to store the stuff
that I'm going to
look at every morning.
So as I'm on my way into the
work or maybe I'm on the train
or something like that, all of
the data that I need is always
up to date so that I can be
like, great, perfect.
And maybe that's something that
the user sets and the
user says, hey, I want to update
this data every morning
at this particular
time, or maybe--
JOE MARINI: It also might be
useful to see how the data
changes throughout the day.
That same snapshot of data
across every hour or so.
PETE LEPAGE: Exactly.
The other thing that you could
use it for is listening for
and updating data from the users
side up to the server.
Because maybe it's something
that the user's
storing stuff locally.
Think something like Google
Docs, where as I'm typing and
storing data locally, maybe I
want to save that up to the
cloud and rather than push it
up every single keystroke or
every bunch of keystrokes, you
can have an alarm fire for
every three minutes or five
minutes or 20 minutes, so that
all the data gets stored
up to the cloud.
But again, pushing and pulling
data is, I think, one of the
primary things that it's going
to get used for, but writing
an alarm clock.
Perfectly great example.
JOE MARINI: Anything that
requires periodic code
execution is a pretty
good use case.
PETE LEPAGE: Exactly.
So Gavin Good from Kingston
wants to know, how do you turn
alarms on and off?
So the way that you turn an
alarm on and off, from a
developer point of view, is you
add the alarm, and then
you can do a clear alarm.
So if we have a look at the API
again, let me just pull
that particular slide up.
And let's see here, I think--
Here we go, yeah.
So you can see here on
this particular--
there's a clear with
a clear name.
So you could provide a name of
the alarm you want to clear,
so that'll turn it off.
And then you just then
add a new one.
JOE MARINI: There's
also a clear all.
You can also--
There's a clear all that will
clear all of them out.
PETE LEPAGE: Exactly.
As a user, you can't turn
them off, but from a
developer you could.
So if you want to be a good
developer, it's probably a
smart idea to allow the user
some way of turning those off
if it's not a core piece of
functionality for your
application.
So if it's maybe just popping
up an alert when there's new
email or something like that,
then, yeah, that's something
you want to give a choice to.
Or maybe you want to allow the
user to choose how often they
want to poll.
So instead of saying, hey, we're
going to poll every 30
seconds or 90 seconds
or minute, you can
definitely do that.
All right.
Let's see, are there any
other questions before
we wrap up for today?
I think that looks like
all the questions.
So Joe, thanks for joining
me this morning and--
JOE MARINI: Thanks
for having me.
I appreciate it.
PETE LEPAGE: Thanks to everybody
for turning it.
We actually are going to
be back again tomorrow.
We have a special edition of
our Chrome Apps, and we're
actually going to be moving our
show to Wednesdays now,
for a whole bunch of reasons.
So we hope you'll join us
starting tomorrow, and we look
forward to seeing you.
All right, well, thanks
everybody.
JOE MARINI: Thanks, everyone.